chuckles brother back outside
[Applause]
his off the cargo box three rows lost
the hand that gets it back now he fires
[Applause]
for Chicago in 21 rebounds those four
bigs at 41 points and 37 rebound it's
been that night so far
Tim's worth said we get whoo man what a
crossover and smart puts his hands like
I could do it
[Applause]
his face take it away from two snails
they're going to trap him as he comes up
freezing you're gonna see a guy try to
shoot the gap right here Derek
recognizes go ahead and roll it he's
looking at T still all the way gets
himself up in there throws a rocket to
Ty's Gibson for the legs here it is
again those were rocket
[Applause]
[Applause]
special indeed Wow to the bag of tricks
getting to the basket
finishing with this offhand a lot of
life in those legs there Rose got his
team playing well at 15 from Roy J Mayo
dental he's got 11 shot clocks winding
down to 2 it goes Rose tough shot to go
up a little bit stronger you've been
talking about playoff basketball right
now he knows a lot yes indeed an
acrobatic layup and you can see he is
turning on floor place guarded by
[Applause]
good too much one-on-one but he's able
to gather right here after the pushin
called
nice off the glass
wookies finds Rose rose trying to get
open fire
[Applause]
so forth from their very poor
[Applause]
Butler steps back roads attacking
butcher
[Applause]
you say a big-time boom I called a
these two Gucci
while as you see the shop might go by
mouth
races to the board it's a three-on-one
rose tonight
Derrick Rose in this is retro and it's
only been a few years retro DeRose going
to their left hand what you have to love
you know he's going to finish but was
the quick quote mattock picked up by
Derrick numbers grows what a fake crab
right out of his socks he thought he was
gonna go to McDermott go to McDermott
look at crab he almost pulled AB muscle
watch crab right here to defensively
watch you know you work on your game
because when I hear he works on his game
tirelessly in the gym so he's working
[Applause]
butter
we're closed
and there's expectations as Butler comes
up with another steal there's
expectations for free agents that they
ought to come inside to more that was
perfect
nation rose more up and under in town
boxes
and then the cat grows for three
takes about he drives to the basket
everybody commits Derrick Rose not the
best three-point shooter but big-time
players make big time plays here it is
driving kick Derrick Rose wide open our
the couple for the Bulls and Felicio
will be couple Rose is wide open
[Applause]
what's that screen right there moody a
gets popped
and then the athletic move by Derrick
Rose and son show that body control of
[Applause]
[Music]
four to look at all the black jerseys
around him I mean this is this is
vintage Derrick Rose right here being
able to finish in traffic with contact a
nice little kiss their left hand
Hiro's not allowing to get comfortable
this what we talked about last night
himself in midair that was a spectacular
move on number one
rose the crossover gets to the ring from
Derrick Rose
but this is the one right here shake and
bake mesmerizing getting to do identity
no he has not lost his identity is
ruffle boots another beauty to the
basket
it's a beautiful stroke of Mira touch
dangerous baskets at the Rose nose
drives underneath laughs OH
beautiful play from rose lightly it's
excellent there it is right there and
then how about this move where he
finishes by coming back up with the
right hit tears the Pistons a 29th in
making three balls Rose penetrates on
Lily
[Applause]
each feet in the air this is a guy who's
had major knee injuries and knee
surgeries it takes a long time five to
shoot down to two rows on a pull-up
jumpers up
[Applause]
go apply for you need a point guard to
make plays down the stretch it makes
everybody's life so much easier put the
ball in Derrick's hands let him go to
work he's come through this whole entire
quarter making plays at the basket there
he makes the big jump shot
Derrick Rose is back gets the rebound
there comes Rose one man to beat a true
get some Rose took some contact as well
well then one reverse it's true virtuoso
improvising off the glass that time off
the wrong foot see how he came off the
wrong foot for hoop fit in with the left
hand three years off the bench as a
member of the Phoenix Suns
take over crowded thrall with this move
by rolls along the beasts line and the
stuff nice masseur twice looses get him
in pain shot clock is down to four
there's rose
[Applause]
nobody's 39th I'm still a pest rose
gonna do it themselves to this first
DeRose coming alive he does that every
night just keep an eye on us this is one
he's on top of his game offensively he
loves coming in here and come up on the
other side he's the one on the best in
the game in that department since he
entered the league now in his seventh
year
[Applause]
and a chance to three-point play
the fender changes his pace gets the
lefthand the gun and the ventures loving
it how about that this year so far
assuming the ball as well an outstanding
shooters Rose the crossover up and under
couple of gorgeous moves from Derrick
Rose we meant that this is awful deep
and some of this is terrific offense but
Russ is getting ready to do it two years
in a row well in the fact that he's
doing it this year when he's got other
weapons around Rose right now he's like
how did you do that I mean that was just
ridiculous
cat in this game the wolf's kicking off
one final cool book here close the
quarter rose in traffic and applaud a
quarter Derrick Rose he gets into the
paint is able to finish it and one and
then the technical foul also Minnesota's
got a chance to get a four-point
possession here are we gonna see a gate
games where teams are half of their
shots are coming from outside oh my
goodness Derrick Rose that was
ridiculous
let's try again here we go oh that was
sweet yes Derrick Rose so now they're
stopped Rose the spin move get some oohs
and ahhs Toliver for threatened over as
we go under four minutes whoa
if the tip rolls wrapped in this game
our Miller Lite hold true moment
courtesy of Derrick Rose and Tim rolls
right now back within four and downtown
Minneapolis lineup combination
standpoint is Minnesota's enjoyed help
that's been a great day
Derrick Rose waits for the big he's
shooting 50% from the floor
he's shooting close to 50% from the
three since the trade I'm talking about
abuse if you take the entire seat
[Applause]
[Music]
deserves to be an all-star he certainly
is tonight again mano-a-mano right there
I mean you're talking about McHale
bridges their best individual defender
if he's got to be feeling a little bit
shell-shocked here on this road trip
because Maskell ciacco hit the
game-winner against him in Toronto
Derrick has 15 in the fourth final 10
seconds tie ballgame in New Orleans
Derrick would the drive over holiday
pizza
[Applause]
is out Derrick Rose wins the ballgame
all away in plenty of time over one
second left 1.2 when he let it fly 81 72
halfway through the third
[Applause]
[Music]
Andre gets a steal ahead of Derrick Rose
lives in beautiful hosta glasses a stop
a sensational play as Andre finishes
with a block running out the clock that
time so the Pistons good defensive
sequence for the hole 24 there's that
beautiful feed off his last this is a
three on one break and that's your best
option right there off the glass up high
no way the defender the lone defender
sax is going to stop
[Applause]
near it grows that gets Chandler
[Applause]
everybody knows what he wants the bigger
question is Finch in a rain of booze up
the triple a little bit strong and
rebounded by morals right down by 14
rows deep in his bag like the Frizer at
the bottom Wow Rose burst that we're
talking about that he still has and just
the ability and the English to go
through the contact boom hits the hole
hits the gap goes around the Andre
Jordan one of the best shot blockers in
this league that is a difficult
difficult shot that anybody in their
prime would